you know you seem like the type of
person that does a lot of due diligence
and research I was I've always been
fascinated with the story of JFK
assassination a lot I've interviewed Jim
Jenkins who was one of the autopsy folks
who was in the room I've sat with Clint
Hill which Clint Hill you obviously know
who Clint Hill is and his interview with
us has around four million views sat
down with Abraham Bolden and sat down
with several different people to talk
about that over the years whether it's
you know 1968 with your father or your
uncle I can only imagine you reading
pretty much anything and everything that
comes up about that topic you know it's
one of the most talked about topics
around the world at what conclusion do
you have so far today with what happened
both with your father and your uncle you
know I have spent a lot of time
researching I actually I'm deep into the
research I did if you read the book you
couldn't see where it's going and I
interviewed people who were you know who
were part of a Cuban CIA group which is
clearly the group that was CIA officials
twice I because the Cubans were so
deeply involved and you know the CIA
Cubans the same ones who were trying to
kill Castro Phillips and Phillips was a
was a CIA a propagandist yet been
involved in the 1953 coup and Guatemalan
State Department's he was at the Bay of
Pigs he was doing propaganda there and
then he
the cuban sabotage program alpha 66
these rating groups and it was people
from that those teams you know we're the
team that was involved in the
assassination lee harvey on it he was
also Lee Harvey Oswald's case officer
originally already Oswald had worked
directly for James Jesus angleton it was
the counterintelligence so Lee Harvey
Oswald in a radar operator at Zoe
Air Force Base and in Japan and that's
where the u2 flights had taken off so
yeah very high-security close top-secret
he D flat he defected to the Soviet in
1957 and and then but his defection was
what they called a dangle it was a real
defection he was actually in CIA asset
from that time and he was working for an
angled enemy the reason for his
defection was that angle that there was
a mole in Langley it's the reason they
never had a good spy in Russia because
as soon as they got somebody who
defected he'd immediately get killed
because there was somebody at Langley
telling Angleton who ran that vision
counterintelligence supposed trap
Russian spies recruited Oswald to make
fake defection to Russia because he
believed he had his file on a trigger
and Langley and they assumed that the
KGB would be wondering who is this guy
is he real and they would contact them
all at Langley and say go pull his file
and tell us what it says so he had a
trigger system eyes on that file so that
he would know if somebody pulled any
know that that was the hole it had never
happened and so as well was recalled
from an ad from Moscow three years later
by then he'd already married the
daughter of a KGB colonel and you know
it came back here with Kareena he was at
the airport never interrogated by the
given money returned by the State
Department $600 he flew to Dallas he was
met by a CIA agent our assets in Dallas
who then took care of him ended up
getting on the job at the Book
Depository who took care of him through
all this so returns but the whole time
he was reporting to two men David
Johanna DS who was who ended up being
the liaison with the Warren Commission
and his job was just hide stuff and of
course Allen Dulles who was the head of
the CIA but my uncle had fired and who
was a chief suspect estimation ran the
Warren Commission got himself appointed
to it and ran to hide the CIA's but
Oswald was you know was a pro Kennedy
guy was really to on Cubans who met
Oswald and met him with David Lee
Phillips you know I think it's you know
at the time the Warren Commission will
hide the CIA involvement but 75 when
they hearts committee met they made the
conclusion that yeah it was a conspiracy
and he actually staff for that committee
all concluded that it was the CIA I
think now we have documentation that
it's really would be almost crazy to
think that we're not you know in terms
of my dad I never believed that there
was a conspiracy I always believed that
Sirhan had acted alone with so much
evidence in his diaries and everything
else and it's saying there were 77
eyewitnesses there were a lot of
problems with the story Oswald could
we know what happened as well was at the
closest a five feet from my father his
hand his body was you know eight feet
that's the closest any fired worst
neuron sirhan sorry sir hadn't met my
father and the Ambassador Hotel kitchen
he was the other steam table my father
walked award him he fired two shots at
my father one of those shots hit Paul
Schrade who was later recognized my
father in the head alive today and very
close friends and it's been trying for
20 years Sirhan out of jail because he
knows he said it and he used the one who
forced Aidid sit down autopsy report etc
yeah under bullet that he fired toward
my father went past life others here and
landed in the doorjamb and was extracted
from the door jambs we know what
happened those two fellows as soon as he
fired those it was a pile on a my Rosie
rare and Rafer Johnson II a concierge
from the hotel a whole bunch of people
who have them and the first thing they
did is pointy it's getting away from my
father the opposite direction but they
couldn't get it away from them Sirhan
fired six other shots and empty the
chamber was it was made shot revolver
and every one of the shots hit somebody
so we know what happened to all of them
there's two shots that way we know what
happened and that was six shots the
other way my father was killed by four
shots from behind and all according to
Thomas Noguchi autopsy Thomas Noguchi
never believes her and used the greatest
you know corner in the history he on he
said every one of those shots left
tattoo on my dad they were all contact
us the barrel of the gun was actually
touching my father when the killer
killed them and so what
surely happening is as a distractor he
was firing the shots he had no memory of
it virtually everybody who's interviewed
on believe that he was under some kind
of hypnosis he fired the shots on and
while people looking focused on him the
purse another person I had four shots
from behind when went through harmlessly
through the shoulder pad of his suit his
head and in every case no one's touching
him now but the the person who almost
certainly fired those shots as a man
called Eugene thanks it was a what he
worked at Lockheed he'd gotten the job
security and three days before he worked
at Lockheed as a high security job he
was as it turns out a CIA agent and he
he was he admitted he was seeing my
father when he fell onto say and as he
was falling he turned around and he tore
off Caesars clip-on tie and so if you
see him and say czar on him he drew his
gun he said he drew his gun when he saw
he changed his story many times about
Ledger's when he stood up he had the gun
out the police ever questioned him at
that time and they never took it away he
later sold the gun sold the gun to
another Lockheed and that gun was trying
has been tracked down says the bullets
that came from Sir hands gun none of
them match the bullets our and my father
oh you know it's impossible it's our
hands off Aaron and
Yujin says I was in negotiations with
him Oh three months ago code to go over
the Philippines to meet with them but he
wanted to charge me $20,000 and he died
at time
[Music]